The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We have
two strings, s1, s2.
First, we're going to
check if the length of s1
is equal length 2.
Anyone, really quickly
can you tell me what
is the length of s1 and s2?
How many characters
are in there?
10 right, because
we're including spaces.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
so they are equal, first of all.
So we're going to go
inside this if statement.
Then we're going to go
for every character in s1.
And then we're going
to have a nested loop.
For every character
in s2, we're going
to check if the two characters
are the same, and if they are,
we're going to print this
common letter statement
and then we're going to break.
OK.
Great we have some
good competition here.
So let's see.
The outer for loop
is first going
to go through the
letter M. So this
is-- so first it's going
to look at M, right.
For char in s1, the first
character in s1 is an M.
Then we're entering inside
this other for loop.
For char 2 in s2.
So I'm going to
say for this M, I'm
going to look at I, which is
the first character in s2.
If the character 1 is equal
to character 2, they're not,
don't do anything.
Keep going to the
next character in s2.
So that-- you don't
do anything there.
The next character
in s2 is a space,
M does not equal a space
so you don't do anything.
R does not-- the next character
is an R, don't do anything.
The next character is
a U, don't do anything.
Then an L, don't do anything.
Then an E, don't do anything.
Space.
And then suddenly
we get to an M.
So we're still in the outer for
loop, we're still looking at M,
and we're comparing M with every
other letter inside the s2.
And suddenly we reach here where
we're comparing M with an M
and when we say
yes, they are equal.
So we're going to
print out something.
Make that into a better check.
We're going to
print common letter
and then we're going to break.
This break says do
not keep looking
at the remaining letters in s2.
So once we've found
one that fits--
once we found one the
matches, stop right here,
break, and print out the thing,
and then go on to looking at I,
which is the next letter in s1.
And you do the same
thing, compare I with I,
we have a match.
Perfect, right off the bat.
So you print out
another common letter.
And then you break, which
means don't keep looking
at the remaining letters.
And then you look at-- since
you broke out of the inner loop,
you go to the outer loop.
The next letter is a
T and so on and so on.
So essentially you're comparing
every letter out here in s1
with every single
letter in s2 until you
find one that matches.
As soon as you do, you exit.
So if you actually
run this program
it's going to print out
seven times, I think.
We can check it.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 times.
Nice.
The majority of the
people are right.
If you got this wrong,
please go back and try
to trace through your program.
That means step by
step try to figure out
what values of
variables are just
to make sure that you're
on the right track
and you understand
exactly what's happening.
OK.